من الصعب جدا واذ مجهود العمر كله من
الشهادات والوثائق الاكاديميه لكن مشاعر
قويه دفعته الى اخذ هذا القرار الصعب كما
يقول اسماعيل مشعل الاستاذ الجامعي الذي
مزق شهاداته في برنامج متلفزن ردا على
قرار طالبانا بمنع الفتيات من
التعليميات الى ان استطيع واتمكن من
الكفاح الذي بداته من اجل سيدتي اللواتي
يبلغ عددهن 20 مليون
فريد احمد من زملائي مشعل في العمليه
التعليميه استاذ جامعي لكنه قدم استقاله
من مهامه التعليميه في الجامعه ايضا يكافح
مع مشعل جنبا الى جنب لاسترجاع الحقوق
التعليميه المشروعه للفتيات
لن نرجع الى مهمتنا المقدسه مهمه التدريس
حتى تفتح جميع ابواب المدارس والمعاهد
والجامعات امام جميع الفتيات في جميع
افغانستان
اسماعيل مشعل يملك حاليا مدرسه ابتدائيه
ومعهدا وجامعه يقول انه عن طلب جميع هذه
المشاريع التعليميه تضامنا مع الفتيات
الافغانيات ويشتغل في مؤسسته الخيريه التي
تقدم خدمات الانسانيه
للمحتاجين في المجتمع الافغاني على اي حال
فان الاستاذ مشعل ليس نادما على تمزيقه
شهادات لكن صنعه ياتي لوجه رساله رفضا
لقرار منع تعليم الفتيات وهو يعلم ان ما
فعله لن يثني طالبانا عن قرارها قبل هذه
العربيه كابول